>> AMERICANS HELD HOSTAGE BEHIND
ENEMY LIES DAY 13.
>> Sean: AMERICA'S HELD HOSTAGE.
THE TIMETABLE IS COMING FAST.
WE'RE NOW FAST APPROACHING
AMERICA'S LAST WEEKEND IN
AFGHANISTAN.
13 OF OUR BRAVE SOLDIERS ARE
DEAD.
THEY WILL NEVER RETURN HOME TO
THEIR FAMILIES.
MORE THAN A DOZEN OTHERS
SERIOUSLY WOUNDED.
A TOTAL DEATH TOLL IS MORE THAN
170, OVER 200 PEOPLE INJURED,
THIS IS AS THOUSANDS OF OUR OWN
CITIZENS, OUR FRIENDS, OUR
AMERICAN FAMILY AND YES,
AMERICAN ALLIES REMAIN TRAPPED,
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY, ALL OF
THEM BEHIND ENEMY LINES, ALL OF
THEM HOSTAGE TO THE WHIM OF THE
TALIBAN AND OTHERS.
IT'S HARDER TO GET INSIDE HAMED
KARZAI AIRPORT.
WE'RE TOLD THE TALIBAN COULD BE
IN FULL CONTROL NOW IN A MATTER
OF DAYS.
SOME PREDICT AS EARLY AS THIS
WEEKEND.
THE WORSE, THE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION AND CARNAGE ALL
EASILY PREVENTIBLE.
SO EASILY PREVENTIBLE.
JOE BIDEN IS DEFIANTLY LOCKED
INTO HIS DISASTROUS DECISION
THAT HAS RENDERED US A FAILURE
HERE.
WHY HE'S TRIPLED DOWN ON THIS
FAILURE IS ANYONE'S GUESS.
WHY HE'S ABIDING BY THE TALIBAN
DEADLINE ALSO A MYSTERY TONIGHT.
WHY HE'S NOT SENDING IN
ADDITIONAL TROOPS TO RESCUE
EVERY SINGLE SOLITARY AMERICAN
BEHIND ENEMY LINES IS
UNFORGIVEABLE.
WHY HE'S SO ACCEPTING OF THE
IDEA THAT AMERICANS WILL BE LEFT
BEHIND IS BEYOND ANYTHING THAT
ANY GOOD AMERICAN THAT I KNOW OF
CAN COMPREHEND.
SADLY TONIGHT, THAT OUTCOME
SEEMS INEVITABLE.
THIS WAS NOT AN INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY FAILURE.
JOE BIDEN IGNORED WHAT ARE
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF WARNINGS ON
THE GROUND AND THEY'VE BEEN
GIVEN TO HIM NOW FOR MONTHS.
OUR SOURCES CONFIRMING, HE
IGNORED HIS OWN MILITARY
ADVISERS.
THAT TOO HAS BEEN ON GOING FOR
MONTHS.
HE IGNORED THE INTEL COMMUNITY.
YOU CAN SEE THE MAP WITH THE
TIME FRAME.
THE RAPID ADVANCE FROM APRIL,
JUNE, JULY AND AUGUST AND
EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN.
YESTERDAY, WHAT DID WE SEE?
MUMBLING, RAMBLING PRESS
CONFERENCE SHOWING THE ENTIRE
WORLD AMERICA'S FRIENDS AND
ALLIES AND YEAH, HOSTILE REGIMES
AND OUR FOES THAT THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA HAS A
COGNITIVELY WEAK, FRAIL AND
COMPLETELY OUT OF TOUCH
PRESIDENT THAT IS CLINGING TO
FAILED POLICIES.
THIS IS BEYOND A NATIONAL
EMBARRASSMENT.
INNOCENT PEOPLE WILL LIKELY DIE
AS A RESULT OF ALL OF THIS.
MORE WILL DOLE.
SO CONGRATULATIONS, JOE.
THIS IS YOUR MISSION
ACCOMPLISHED.
13 AMERICAN FAMILIES WILL NEVER
BE THE SAME.
MANY MORE BRAVE SERVICE MEN WILL
STRUGGLE WITH SERIOUS INJURIES
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES AND MORE
THAN 100 INNOCENT CIVILIANS HAVE
PERISHED.
THIS IS A NIGHTMARE.
A FAILURE OF EPIC PROPORTIONS.
THE WORST FOREIGN POLICY
DISASTER IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY
WITH DEADLY REAL-LIFE
CONSEQUENCES AND RISKS THAT
REMAIN HIGHER THAN EVER.
REMEMBER, JUST LAST WEEK, BIDEN
SAID ANY ATTACK ON OUR FORCES OR
DISRUPTION OF OUR OPERATIONS AT
KARZAI INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
WILL BE MET WITH SWIFT AND
FORCEFUL RESPONSE.
NOW THAT SWIFT AND FORCEFUL
RESPONSE IS NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
JUST LIKE SO MANY OTHER BIDEN
PROMISES.
THOSE WORDS APPEAR TO BE TOTALLY
COMPLETELY HOLLOW.
SEEMINGLY LIKE WHAT IS IN HIS
HEAD AT MOST HOURS OF THE DAY
IS.
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS WE
WILL HUNT YOU DOWN AND MAKE YOU
PAY, WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
IS HE GOING TO ORD AREA MISSION
TO KILL THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE
OR WOULD HE WILL SATISFIED IF
THEY'RE CAPTURED AND BROUGHT TO
TRIAL?
>> HE MADE CLEAR YESTERDAY THAT
HE DOESN'T WANT THEM TO LIVE ON
THE EARTH ANYMORE.
>> Sean: IN OTHER WORDS, THERE'S
NO PLAN OF ACTION OTHER THAN A
STERN TALKING TO.
EVEN OBAMA'S DEFENSE SECRETARY,
EVEN FORMER CIA DIRECTOR, HE DID
BOTH JOBS, LEON PANETTA RIGHTLY
IS CALLING FOR A SWIFT MILITARY
RESPONSE.
I DON'T AGREE WITH HIM
POLITICALLY BUT HE KNOW WHAT'S
HE'S TALKING ABOUT HERE.
THIS MORNING JOE BIDEN HIMSELF
COULD NOTE BE BOTHERED TO ANSWER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN.
ESPECIALLY AFTER AND IN LIGHT OF
YESTERDAY'S DISASTER.
NOT EVEN THEY TOLD ME TO CALL ON
WHOEVER BEING DICTATED BY HIS
STAFF.
HE DOESN'T WANT THEM TO GET MAD
AT HIM.
OBVIOUSLY THEY CALL THE SHOTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I MET WITH MY COMMANDERS THIS
MORNING FIRST THING IN THE
MORNING.
GOT A DETAILED BRIEFING ABOUT
YESTERDAY'S ATTACKS AND THE
MEASURES THEY'RE TAKING TO
PROTECT OUR FORCES AND COMPLETE
THE MISSION.
AND WE MR. COMPLETE THE MISSION.
I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS BECAUSE OF THE PRIME
MINISTER BEING HERE ON
AFGHANISTAN NOW.
I'LL BE AVAILABLE AT ANOTHER
TIME.
>> Sean: I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
I MIGHT GET YELLED AT AGAIN.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO AMERICANS
CLEARLY NOW?
IT'S INEVITABLE.
WE'LL LEAVE THEM BEHIND.
HOW WILL THEY EVER GET OUT?
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO PROTECT
THEM?
WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO KARZAI
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT IN KABUL
WHEN WE DO PULL OUT?
WHAT WILL JOE DO IF FOR
AMERICANS ARE MURDERED LIKE
YESTERDAY?
WHAT WILL HE DO IF THE TALIBAN
MURDERS AN AFGHAN WITH ONE OF
OUR SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISAS, THE
ONE THAT WE MADE A PLEDGE THAT
IF IT EVER CAME TO THIS, WE
WOULD GET YOU THE HELL OUT OF
THERE?
WE DIDN'T KEEP OUR WORD TO THEM.
MANY WILL DIE.
JOE GAVE THEM A LIST OF NAMES SO
THEY NOW HAVE A DATABASE,
BIOMETRICS AND JOE'S LIST.
THEY'RE BEING HUNTED DOWN AS WE
SPEAK.
THEY'RE EXECUTED ONE AFTER THE
OTHER.
HOW DO MANY AMERICANS -- WE
STILL DON'T GET AN ANSWER, ARE
STILL IN AFGHANISTAN.
HOW MANY AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
EVACUATED?
THEY DON'T KNOW.
HOW WILL HE PREVENT THE RISE OF
ISIS OF AL-QUAIDA WITH NO
EMBASSY?
WE WERE IN WAR WITH THEM, THE
9-11 COMMISSION REPORT.
YOU ALL, ALL THE PLOTTING AND
PLANNING AND SCHEMING THAT TOOK
PLACE INSIDE OF AFGHANISTAN AND
THE LEAD UP TO 9-11, 2001, 20
YEARS AGO.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO THE $83
BILLION, JOE BIDEN, THE WEAPONS
THAT HE LEFT BEHIND, THE MOST
POWERFUL WEAPONRY OF ANY
MILITARY FORCE ON THE FACE OF
THE EARTH?
HE GAVE TO IT TERRORISTS?
IT'S A LITTLE TOO LATE.
NOW WE HAVE IMAGES OF TALIBAN
FLYING OUR BLACKHAWK ATTACK HELL
CONTINUERS OR RIDING AROUND IN
OUR ARMORED VEHICLES.
208 HELICOPTERS AND AIRCRAFT HE
LEFT BEHIND.
HOW DOES BIDEN PLAN TO VET WHAT
IS NOW TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AFGHAN REFUGEES?
AS WE SPEAK, THERE'S SHOE MANY
REFUGEES FLYING IN TO WASHINGTON
D.C. APPARENTLY THEY'RE DOING
THE VETTING AFTER PEOPLE ARE IN
THE AIR FLYING TO THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S CAUSING A MASSIVE BOTTLE
NECK AT DULLES INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT.
WE NEED TO KNOW HOW THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING VETTED.
REPORTS THAT ALREADY OVER 100
PEOPLE THAT HAVE COME TO AMERICA
FROM AFGHANISTAN ARE ALSO ON OUR
TERRORIST WATCH LISTS.
CLEARLY THERE'S A LOT OF
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO
BE ANSWERED.
JOE BIDEN, HIS INCOHERENT
MUMBLING AND BUMBLING AND
UNWILLNESS AND UNABILITY TO
ANSWER THEM IS CHILLING.
YESTERDAY DURING A BIZARRE --
ONE OF HIS BIZARRE MOMENTS AT
THAT PRESS CONFERENCE, JOE BIDEN
WAS COMPLETELY DAZED AND
CONFUSED WITH AN IMAGE THAT WENT
VIRAL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TERRORISTS ATTACKED -- THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT,
WORRIED ABOUT, THAT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY HAS
ASSESSED -- HAS UNDERTAKEN AN
ATTACK BY A GROUP KNOWN AS
ISIS-K.
GAVE ME A LIST HERE.
THE FIRST PERSON I WAS
INSTRUCTED TO CALL ON IS KELLY
O'DONNELL OF NBC.
GETTING EVERY SINGLE PERSON OUT
IS -- CAN'T BE GUARANTEED BY
ANYBODY BECAUSE OF THE
DETERMINATION ALL WHO WANTS TO
GET OUT AS WELL.
NOW, WAIT A MINUTE.
I'M ASKING YOU A QUESTION.
IS THAT ACCURATE THE BEST OF
YOUR KNOWLEDGE?
>> [QUESTION INAUDIBLE]
>> LOOKING A IT THIS WAY, FOLKS.
I'M GOING TO -- I HAVE ANOTHER
MEETING FOR REAL.
I KNOW IT'S NOT FAIR TO ASK YOU
QUESTIONS.
IT'S RHETORICAL.
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE GONE.
>> THIS IMAGE OF AN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT?
THAT'S WHY I'VE BEEN SAYING
SOMEBODY SO WEAK AND FRAIL AND A
COGNITIVE MESS.
AMERICA DESERVES BETTER.
WE DON'T LEAVE OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS, OUR FELLOW AMERICANS
BEHIND.
WE RESCUE OUR FELLOW MILES PER
HOURS TRAPPED BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
WE RESPOND TO TERROR ATTACKS
WITH OVERWHELMING FORCE.
WE HAVE THE GREATEST MILITARY ON
THE FORCE OF THE EARTH.
WE STRIKE FEAR INTO THE HEARTS
OF ALL OF OUR ENEMIES AND
INSTILL CONFIDENCE IN ALL OF OUR
ALLIES.
UNDER BIDEN, NONE OF THAT HAS
HAPPENED AND CLEARLY WILL
HAPPEN.
MADE THAT CLEAR YESTERDAY.
THE ONE THING THAT WAS CLEAR.
NO MORE MILITARY PRESENCE.
WE'RE GETTING OUT.
STICKING TO THE TIMETABLE AND
YEAH, THERE WILL BE AMERICANS
LEFT BEHIND IN ALL LIKELIHOOD.
NOW WE'RE SUFFERING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF HIS REAL
WEAKNESSES IN REAL TIME.
MARK MY WORDS, WITH SO MANY
TRAPPED, THIS C